good afternoon everybody it's a pleasure
to be here I've heard a lot of good
things about the program at Yale so it's
really an honor for me to be with you
this afternoon and I'd like to thank dr.
Humphreys for inviting me to be here so
I will and welcome to the group at you
UConn chip be happy to engage in any
discussions later on as well I'll be
covering sort of some aspects related to
nutrition and infectious diseases in
general fortunately it's a wide field
and increasingly there is more and more
work that's being done in this area so
but i'll try to cover some some part of
that briefly some on vitamin A and
infection in general a little bit on
zinc in diarrhea AR I particularly some
discussion about I am particularly with
relation to malaria multivitamins on
hiv/aids and then I'll end with some
concluding remarks in terms of the
distribution of nutritional problems
some of these slides may not be coming
out as good as they were with so I'll
hopefully they'll be clear much of the
distribution of nutritional problems
you'd find a map like this where this
one shows children who are moderately or
severely stunted children who are
underweight children who are wasted and
the distribution of exclusive
breastfeeding in various countries and
the trend seems to be always more or
less the same that a lot of the
nutritional burden is in developing
countries and a lot of it is in
sub-saharan Africa in South Asia you
know large countries of South Asia
particularly India Nepal and others
nearby and a large part of sub-saharan
Africa
that will also be the same distribution
for child mortality and morbidity so
there are about close to eight or nine
million deaths under the age of five
every year and a majority of these are
in sub-saharan Africa and in South Asia
as you can see by the density of the
redness on the map the question really
is is there a relationship between these
two conditions under nutrition on one on
one hand and morbidity and mortality on
the other some of the earlier studies
looked at in various studies really
these are a number of trials and on the
x-axis is the weight for age and you see
that as weight-for-age got worse
mortality was significantly higher that
is in countries that range from
Bangladesh Papua New Guinea Tanzania and
others if you look at that by all causes
mode of mortality which is sore the last
row you see that as you would expect
with worsening of nutritional status
minus 12 minus two standard deviations
minus 2 2-3 or less than minus 3 the
relative risks tend to be significantly
higher not only for all causes of death
but also for cause specific mortality
diarrhea pneumonia measles and other
infectious diseases you would see that's
really not only for those who are minus
2 and lower but even for those who are
less the sort of between minus 1 and
minus 2 which tends to be usually
thought of as not as severely that they
are mildly undernourished in many cases
the definition of wasting and something
is below minus 2 you'd find even those
who are mildly undernourished they're
still tends to be a significant increase
in mortality so it's really a spectrum
and a gradient that leads to higher
morbidity and mortality the causes of
death among children under the age of
five
these are all known it's thought that
malnutrition contributes in a prominent
way to most of these conditions the
range is between thirty to fifty percent
of deaths are possibly related to under
nutrition and by implication that
perhaps by intervening on the
nutritional status of individuals either
by preventing malnutrition or treating
malnutrition that we can have an impact
on reducing childhood mortality there is
this cyclically relationship that we're
all familiar with where infectious
disease leads to an impairment of
nutritional status through a number of
potential mechanisms reduced intake
malabsorption increased losses increase
catabolic processes as a result of the
infectious disease and in turn sort of
the question out there that's more so
the frequently studied is is nutrition
having an impact on the incidence and
severity of infectious diseases and
given that there is this cyclically
relationship and a vicious cycle that
ends up in mortality in most cases is
there a way to intervene and interrupt
the vicious cycle perhaps through
nutritional interventions so we have
looked at some of these with respect to
a number of micronutrients these are the
MDGs that were familiar with the first
one eradicating extreme hunger and under
way sort of the nutrition MDGs that is
referred to sometimes in mdg four five
and six with a focus on child mortality
maternal mortality and infectious
diseases and there is substantial
evidence that there is an important role
for nutrition to address these various
MDGs and a movement by a number of
organizations UN systems World Bank
academic institutions to see that
nutrition plays an important role in
achieving the mdgs by 2015
so it started with vitamin A
supplementation vitamin A deficiency is
prevalent in much of sub-saharan Africa
and South Asia it's more severe in
sub-saharan Africa and South Asia some
of it is still evident in Latin America
but perhaps not as severe a number of
trials earlier on have looked at the
role of vitamin A in measles and perhaps
that's one of the classic examples of
the importance of nutritional
interventions in the context of an
infectious disease two trials in South
Africa one intends and year and one in
London as early as 1930 32 published in
the lancet showing that vitamin A to
individuals who are hospitalized with
pneumonia tends to have a beneficial
impact on mortality as well as morbidity
so the children who are hospitalized
with measles and given vitamin A tend to
have less morbidity less GI
complications less skin rash less
pneumonia less mortality as a result of
the supplementation and it is part of
standard of care in many most settings
developed or developing countries the
u.s. included where part of the
management of measles is provision of
vitamin A supplementation the question
is are there other infectious diseases
or our other nutritional interventions
that have as clear and impact to reach
that level of evidence and level of
program implementation and that's what
we will talk about a little bit some of
the evidence on vitamin A and other
conditions have been looked at these are
trials that look at vitamin A in general
mortality all cause mortality there are
eight trials but there are a few others
that have been done after that
essentially children who are apparently
healthy large numbers of them who have
been randomized to zinc sorry to vitamin
a or a control group placebo in many
cases
and this is a meta-analysis essentially
a relative risk of one is here this
vertical line and anything to the left
of the line suggests beneficial impact
of periodic vitamin A supplementation
given every three to six months overall
showing at twenty-three percent
reduction in children mortality with
this periodic supplementation these are
supplements that are given periodically
to children who are six months of age
and older much of the evidence from
these trials and others have led many
organizations to adopt vitamin A
supplementation as a child survival
strategy it is implemented in many
countries 70 80 countries around the
world as an important tool to reduce
under-five mortality there is a little
bit of controversy about vitamin A
supplementation in the first six months
of life and there is much less evidence
that vitamin A is beneficial in that age
group there are efforts to piggyback it
onto the EPI schedule without really
much evidence that that is beneficial
more recently there is greater
controversy about neonatal vitamin A
supplementation giving it at birth and
its potential impact on infant mortality
with some mixed results some suggesting
benefit in a few countries in Asia a
couple in Africa that suggest there is
no benefit and a large multicenter study
is about to start commissioned by the
Gates Foundation and wh 0 in three
countries Tanzania India and Ghana and
we are part of that effort and hopefully
in a couple of years we'll have some
findings on that on vitamin A it has an
impact on all-cause mortality but also
on the area specific mortality and
measles mortality this is the six months
of age onwards
there are some paradoxical effects on
whether vitamin A has an impact possibly
a negative impact on acute low
respiratory infection essentially more
than one study suggested that children
who are six months of age and older who
received vitamin A tended to have higher
incidence of fever or fever with rapid
respiratory rate a composite of symptoms
that suggest lower respiratory infection
but the reassuring part of that is that
there was no impact on pneumonia related
mortality many of the same trials that
have reported an adverse effect on
morbidity and some of the sort of the
findings that are reported with a higher
occurrence of fever and respiratory rate
is sort of thought to be perhaps more a
manifestation of an improved
inflammatory response that could be
beneficial to the baby so in spite of
these paradoxical effects on acute Loras
bladder infection it is adopted as a
beneficial intervention in most settings
particularly settings where there is
vitamin A deficiency this is a trial
from Tanzania that looked at vitamin A
among HIV negative and HIV positive kids
some impact on height that was more
evident among hiv-positive children this
is comparing the vitamin A to the
placebo some impact on weight changes
that's more evident among children who
have had a malaria episode but not among
those who did not have malaria
essentially suggesting that vitamin A
ameliorates the negative impact of
infectious diseases on height and weight
of children as one of the mechanisms
through which it would also improve
survival potential this is one trial
that looked at vitamin A in malaria in
Papua New Guinea and again suggested a
beneficial impact on malaria vitamin A
is one of the nutrients is most of you
know it has been sort of mostly studied
and there are tens of trials out there
that looked at just vitamin A so a
sample of the findings are what I have
presented today so that's briefly on
vitamin A some more work has been done
on zinc
zinc deficiency follows the same pattern
of vitamin A deficiency in that it is
mostly in sub-saharan Africa and South
Asia where the diets are limited in zinc
where the source of zinc is mostly from
plant sources and phytates and other
ingredients in the diet are inhibitors
of zinc absorption leading to a wide
widespread zinc deficiency in these
populations zinc like many other
micronutrients has been shown to be
important for the functionality of the
immune system there are many trials that
have looked at that many observational
studies human studies as well as animal
studies essentially showing that most
levels of the immune system cellular
immunity and humoral immunity systemic
or or mucosal are affected by zinc
deficiency and a number of observational
studies have noted that zinc deficiency
is associated with a higher risk of
morbidity and mortality and the question
arose is whether zinc supplementation
therefore has a beneficial impact on
these outcomes so these are trials that
have looked at zinc among children with
respect to incidence and prevalence of
diarrhea so on the left is incident on
the right the prevalence in various
trials Jamaica Guatemala Vietnam and so
on with a pooled benefit pooled effect
size of about a twenty five or twenty
twenty to twenty-five percent reduction
in the risk of diarrheal disease among
children other trials have looked at
different types of sort of interventions
for both diarrhea and pneumonia the
variety of trials examined
different interventions either giving it
to people who have an acute episode of
disease and looking at the recovery from
diarrhea or respiratory infection and
found the beneficial impact others have
looked at children who are apparently
healthy and examine whether there is an
impact on the incidence and severity of
new episodes and others have given short
courses versus a continuous long bankers
from the variety of studies that have
been done there tends to be enough
evidence that zinc is important in the
management of diarrhea it has been
adopted as part of the wh 0 guidelines
for management of the ideal disease zinc
ORS is part of practice that's being
disseminated as widely as possible in
the raw number of operational research
studies that are ongoing to see how that
could be put into practice with respect
to pneumonia the evidence is a little
bit not as strong there are two or three
trials that are ongoing in Bangladesh in
Ecuador a couple other places looking at
children with pneumonia and whether
provision of zinc supplements versus
placebo has a beneficial impact there
these various studies have also looked
at zinc and growth and this is a sort of
zero growth height changes comparing
zinc versus placebo and overall you can
see sort of range of potential effect
sizes when you pull them there was a net
beneficial impact with respect to linear
growth and similarly with respect to
weight gain over the various trials
one study a couple of studies have
looked at zinc supplementation on
mortality in the sort of the evidence in
the nutrition community in international
attrition community seems to always want
sort of an impact on survival as the
strongest line of evidence perhaps a
carryover from the work of vitamin A
where a number of studies have been done
to look at mortality specifically large
enough to have an impact on mortality so
a couple of trials were done on zinc to
examine the impact on mortality one was
in pemba tanzania is about 20,000
children who received link and another
20,000 who received placebo and overall
there was no impact on mortality sort of
relative risk of point 93 which wasn't
significant stratifying by age there was
an impact among children who were older
than one year of age but not among
infants the evidence with respect to a
large impact on mortality is not there
as much as it is much clearer in the
case of management of diarrheal disease
moving on to some of the work on aion so
this is the distribution of anemia and
perhaps anemia is the most common
nutritional problem worldwide it's
common in developed settings as well as
in developing countries severity tends
to be greater in developing countries
again sub-saharan Africa Asia and parts
of Latin America but it is not uncommon
even in the u.s. among particular groups
tends to be milder in these populations
malaria is one factor or one sort of
cause of anemia in many of these
settings particularly in settings where
malaria is endemic particularly in
Africa but it's really only one factor
we tend to think of iron deficiency as a
problem and it is a problem but it's not
the only problem there are other
nutritional problems that contribute to
anemia vitamins B vitamins vitamin A has
a role in the prevention of anemia if
you look at the interaction between
vitamin A and zinc there is an important
interaction there there are some
negative interactions between zinc and
iron that would be important to think
about in the context of the nutritional
etiology of anemia and then there are
infectious diseases sister so many other
parasitic infections that are important
in the etiology of anemia either through
blood blood loss or other sort of
manifestations of loss of appetite or or
other
factors that contribute to anemia and
then there is sickle cell disease which
is much more common in particular
populations than in others but not all
any is iron deficiency anemia as is sort
of commonly thought of with that in mind
what's the influence of iron
supplementation in there are it has been
controversy on sort of his iron
supplementation good or bad and it gets
complicated with malaria particularly so
one of the earlier studies was a study
there are many but this is one of the
earlier ones among Somali nomads who
were being managed for famine and with
the introduction of nutritional
interventions including iron supplements
they noted the investigators noted that
there was an increase occurrence of
malaria study in Papua New Guinea
suggested that iron supplementation led
to an increase in parasite density and
morbidity in that setting more recent
work in tanzania and zanzibar did not
find that impact but the controversy has
been on and off for a long time is
maleeh is iron supplementation
contributing to the occurrence of
malaria or is it not our iron
supplements beneficial so a number of
trials have looked at that where iron
was given versus placebo come back to
the summary in a second but these are
some of the studies essentially that
examined hemoglobin levels many of these
settings have anemia and so presumably
pion supplementation would be beneficial
and indeed it was if you look at so this
is again hemoglobin levels and zero is
no impact
anything to the right suggests an impact
a positive impact protective impact in
hemoglobin levels the changes in size
but in most cases is beneficial with a
pooled estimate that is overall
significant 1.2 that is statistically
significant if you look at the risk of
anemia as a categorical variable I
believe I don't remember exactly
definition of perhaps less than 11 maybe
the definition 11 grams per deciliter
about a fifty percent reduction in the
risk well civilian email would be would
be we wouldn't be 11 would be eight
point five or seven we can go back to
that to the paper so a significant
reduction of fifty percent in the risk
of severe anemia with iron
supplementation but was it also
associated with malaria and in many of
these studies they have examined that
question there was a borderline impact
in parasitaemia in these studies so I a
supplementation was associated with
about a nine percent increase in the
risk of clinical clinical malaria
clinical with a positive blood slide and
about a seventeen percent increase in
the risk of parasitaemia without
necessarily clinical outcomes so some of
the conclusions from that there are 13
trials that have been sort of carried
out in various settings Ethiopia
Tanzanian Papua New Guinea and others
various dosing regimens were used only
one was intra muscular parenteral to
intramuscular most of them were almost
all of them are iron supplements and by
and large significant impact noted on
the risk of anemia and severe anemia
with an adverse effect on Plasmodium
falciparum so this is the conclusion
that came out of the paper the
investigators noted moderate increases
in some manner geometric indices however
there were improvements in hematological
status that were very clear and
significant there's no evidence of
exacerbation of malaria metric indices
for doses of 10 milligrams per day in
preschool children and that really led
to a continuation of current practices
at that time that iron supplementation
makes a lot of sense in settings where
there is a lot of anemia the concerns
about malaria do not seem to be big and
the benefits are clear until a trial was
done in pemba Tanzania that looked at
routine iron supplementation to children
this was a factorial design study that
compared nearly four regiments but for
the purposes of the iron question the
examine iron compared to a group that
did not receive iron iron was twelve
point five milligrams as you can see I
was placebo-controlled and half the
doses were given to children who were
infants the trial ended by the DSMB
because of increased hospitalizations
and death in the groups receiving iron
some of the findings iron
supplementation was associated with a
significant increase in admission to
hospital an increase in mortality it was
a borderline significance and largely
quite possibly an issue of statistical
power and a significant increase in the
composite endpoint of admission or have
death which was a severe adverse event
in that particular study with a large
study well conducted well analyzed took
a long time for it to be sort of vetted
and checked the data was checked and
rechecked many times with support of wh
0 and the investigators and the findings
stood these are their findings from the
paper that was published in the lancet
essentially showing the same impact a
significant increase in mortality or
hospital admission in the ion group that
led to a revision of the guidelines
which was one of the slides are
inadvertently cut out essentially w.h.o
came out with the revised guidelines the
guidelines said previously that it makes
all the sense to give routine iron
supplementation two children in settings
where iron deficiency anemia is
prevalent the new guidelines said
something like caution should be
exercised in settings where the
prevalence of malaria and other
infectious diseases are high
well most settings that i know of have
high prevalence of malaria and
infectious diseases and as well as
wasn't clear really what this caution
needs to be exercised mean practically
on the ground one approach is it
continues it is advised that iron folic
acid supplementation be targeted to
those who are anemic anemic or at risk
of iron deficiency the implication of
that is sort of screening program which
is expensive and logistically
challenging in many settings
particularly in rural settings and so
practically what's happening probably is
in settings where there is malaria
intervention programs in place these
concerns might be less likely some of
the work actually from the same paper if
you go back you notice that the evidence
of harm was more clear among those who
are iron sufficient and not among those
who are iron deficient so in the same
population there are individuals who are
iron deficient who benefited from
supplementation and in programs that
would be expected to be the case so
whatever there is evidence of iron
deficiency there is no question that
iron supplementation is beneficial in
instances where they are not deficient
it's where concern needs to be to be
there and caution needs to be exercised
one of the questions really that is out
there as a result of this trial is what
are the implications for pregnant women
in many of the same settings where iron
supplementation is standard of care it's
part of standard prenatal care and
whether similar concerns should be had
about the potential canary sort of risks
of iron supplementation in those
settings there is a trial is about to
start in dar Salam
with our group that will look at that
and hopefully have some answers in the
next couple of years
moving on to HIV as the third infectious
disease that or the next infectious
disease we could look at about a
majority of hiv-infected individuals
live in sub-saharan Africa out of the 30
million plus more than close to seventy
percent are in sub-saharan Africa
disproportionate to the number of people
who live in that part of the world it is
a problem that is expanding in South
Asia as well in sub-saharan Africa tends
to be more as because everybody in seara
knows everything about HIV I don't need
to go into that but and has its impact
on the life expectancy sort of sort of
leading to a dip in in life expectancy
anticipated as a result of the epidemic
and some of these sort of earlier
expectations and so there are modelling
exercises that went further out into the
future hopefully that is being sort of
reversed so to speak or slowed down by
the more widespread availability of
treatment which is still far from
desirable but still much better than
what used to be the case if you if you
look at the cyclic a relationship
between infection and HIV infection and
nutritional status in this case it's
evident one of the issues is limited
availability of food HIV impacts the
most productive sector of society
including farmers and then others so
there is food security problems in many
countries where HIV is prevalent it's
evident that HIV leads to wasting and
it's used to be known as slim disease in
the earlier parts of the epidemic so
there is less debate perhaps about how
HIV leads to malnutrition through
insecurity food insecurity and through
various catabolic on and other processes
malabsorption but
whether nutrition has a role to play in
the treatment and prevention of HIV is
something that has been looked at and we
have looked at and I'll share some of
the findings but the the natural sort of
immediate sort of hypothesis that comes
to mind based on the coexistence of HIV
in malnutrition in many of the same
countries the ecologic relationship that
is from the coexistence the the fact
that protein energy malnutrition and
AIDS have many common manifestations a
reactivation of opportunistic infections
such as TB similar mune deficiency
syndromes where there is nutritional
immune deficiency or HIV related
provided some of the reasoning for
looking more closely at whether
nutrition has a role to play in HIV
current treatment so one of the earlier
observational studies was this one done
by Richard Samba and colleagues at
Hopkins and Malawi where they looked at
vertical transmission of HIV as it
relates to and the y axis serum vitamin
A and they found a very nice those
response relationship the higher the
vitamin A the lower the risk of
mother-to-child transmission and
reasonably speculated that vitamin A
could be important for preventing
mother-to-child transmission a number of
other studies supported that studying in
Kenya that found a similar dose-response
relationship with shedding of the virus
in breast milk or shedding of the virus
in lower genital tract that suggests you
know how that could lead to a higher
transmission through the two mechanisms
or through the two roots there is
biological plausibility vitamin A is
important for immune function there is a
nice dose-response relationship it's a
strong relative risk so
of trials we're done to look at that and
this is one study that we have done in
Tanzania among pregnant women about a
thousand pregnant women who were
enrolled in a factorial design study
with vitamin A or placebo in each group
we randomized to multi vitamins or
placebo essentially having four groups
vitamin A alone multivitamins alone
which was b-complex C and E a group that
received both and number four was a
placebo and in a factorial design we
compare those two groups that received
vitamin A to the two that did not
receive vitamin A and similarly for the
multivitamins so the multi vitamins b c
and e without a BCE compared to placebo
had beneficial impact on fetal loss
about the forty percent reduction and
about the similar magnitude in the
impact on miscarriage and stillbirth
which wasn't significant but about the
same magnitude fetal death was the
composite endpoint with higher
statistical power to examine that
multivitamins also have a beneficial
impact on low birth weight about a forty
percent reduction as well as in severe
preterm birth and small for gestational
age if you look at that it's the same
finding which is not very clear the red
it's essentially the same finding this
vertical line is a relative risk of one
with beneficial impact for small for
gestational age in low birth weight and
fetal death for the multivitamins
compared to the normal t vitamins for
vitamin A there was no impact on any of
these outcomes vitamin A compared to
know vitamin A if you look at the
multivitamins with respect to child HIV
transmission again by and large no
effect on any of these outcomes
but when you look at vitamin A and its
relationship with transmission of the
virus there was I don't know if you can
can you see the slide can you see any of
the horizontal lines so so it's relative
risk of one this is a total HIV
transmission through the three roots
there was a thirty-nine percent higher
risk of transmission that was
significant relative risks not
encompassing 14 total HIV transmission
about the same magnitude for
transmission through breastfeeding as a
result of vitamin A supplementation
these are the same findings perhaps in
numbers about thirty-eight percent
higher risk of transmission that was
significant which wasn't the hypothesis
that we set out to look at the
hypothesis was more coming out of the
Malawi study that vitamin A is
beneficial for various biological
reasons a lot of excitement about
vitamin A with respect to child survival
in many trials prior to that that
supported a potential benefit of vitamin
A in the context of HIV as well but that
is not what was found after a lot of
checking and counter checking of the
data as well in retrospect there are
other studies that perhaps raised
concerns about vitamin A in the context
of HIV in happy to discuss more if time
allows but this is one in this is Alice
tang and her colleagues this was the max
cohort the multicenter dates cohort
study in the u.s. that enrolled
homosexual bisexual men in the u.s.
hiv-positive and followed them up over
time to look at time to aids and assess
their dietary intake of vitamin A or
other nutrients and found with respect
to vitamin A these are the turtles of
vitamin intake this is the second third
tile individuals who are in the first
and third
a turtle of vitamin A intake tended to
have worse outcomes compared to those
who are in the Middle tertile suggesting
a u-shaped relationship that perhaps
hasn't been looked at carefully at that
time that not only low intake was
problematic but perhaps higher intake of
vitamin A might be problematic and there
are a number of observational studies in
in vitro studies that raise concerns
about vitamin A in that context in the
context of HIV with respect to
multivitamins there was no impact of
multivitamins on transmission overall as
I have shown in an earlier slide but
when you look at modifiers of the
relationship you stratify by a nympho
site count so look at stratifying by low
lymphocyte versus high lymphocyte those
who have maternal lymphocyte count
mothers who had low lymphocyte count and
received multivitamins had about a sixty
percent reduction in the risk of
transmission compared to those who did
not receive multivitamins women with
high lymphocyte count did not benefit
and this is the p for interaction
similarly women who had low hemoglobin
who had high ESR suggestive of an
advanced disease stage and babies who
are born with a low birth weight tended
to have a beneficial impact if their
mothers received the supplements and the
mothers received the supplements during
pregnancy but continued to receive it in
the period after delivery for as long as
the trial continued which was an average
about five years after delivery during
which the children were breastfeeding so
possibly enhancing maternal immune
function improving quality of life for
the mother improving the quality of
breast milk that the babies were
receiving could have had an impact on
the transmission question
we looked at multi vitamins in our trial
and in other studies and how they relate
to disease progression sort of separate
from transmission mother to child and
the same max cohort found beneficial
impact of multi vitamins as well as
individual vitamins on mortality
particularly B vitamins when they are
taken in multiples of the RDA about a
forty percent reduction in mortality
among those who had higher levels of
intake of B vitamins compared to those
who had low levels a similar study from
a population in South Africa in
Johannesburg regular use of B vitamins
an observational study was beneficial a
small trial that looked at 50
individuals with high doses of vitamin C
and E and found an improvement in C and
E levels as you would expect but a trend
towards reduced viral load in those who
received C and E a trial in Thailand
this is our published studies all the
studies that I'm coating found a
beneficial impact of multivitamins
particularly among those who had low cd4
cell count CD for less than 200 relative
risk of point 37 compared to those who
received a placebo and in the same
Tanzania study comparing the forearms
really those who receive b c and e
compared to placebo had about thirty
percent reduction in mortality or
progression to stage for the majority of
individuals where in stage one at
enrollment and with that there was about
thirty percent reduction in progression
to stage four or mortality these are the
kaplan-meier curves on the same study
and in the same study a significant
benefit with multivitamins on various
sort of signs and
conditions associated with HIV disease
progression gingival erythema oral
ulcers nausea vomiting a number of GI
manifestations of advanced HIV disease
that were significantly reduced with
multivitamins with respect to vitamin A
there was no benefit on either mortality
or morbidity there was a significant
improvement in cd4 cell counts with
multivitamins and the reduction in the
risk of wasting as well in the same
study there were beneficial impacts on
child outcomes as well so children who
were born to mothers who receive
multivitamins had better hemoglobin
levels reduced risks of anemia better
motor development better growth and
unless morbidity over the period of the
first two years of life I have a few
more slides but they would be showing
many of the same and maybe I should stop
here rather than keep keep showing your
slides to see if you have any questions
thank you very much